[CROWD CHEERING]
>> Jon: WELCOME YOUNG MAN.
>> THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
>> Jon: HAVE YOU RECOVERED
FROM THE LIVE PORTION, THE
BEACON THEATRE PORTION.
>> YEAH.
>> Jon: OF NIGHT OF TOO MANY
STARS?
>> IT'S A HARD GIG.
>> Jon: SATURDAY NIGHT.
I HAVE NOT RECOVERED AND IT'S
NOT OVER.
>> Jon: IT'S NOT OVER BY A
LONGSHOT.
>> IT'S NOT OVER, WE'RE DOING A
LIVE PHONE BANK ON SUNDAY NIGHT.
>> Jon: THIS SUNDAY NIGHT.
>> THAT'S WHEN THE SHOW AIRS,
YES.
>> Jon: BUT I'VE GOT TO TELL
YOU --
>> YES.
>> DOING THIS A WHILE, LAST --
IT WAS SATURDAY NIGHT --
>> YEAH.
>> Jon: I'M TELLING YOU, I
THOUGHT MORE INSANE THINGS
HAPPENED THAT SATURDAY
NIGHT THAN IN ANY SHOW
THAT WE'VE DONE SO
FAR WITH THIS.
>> YES.
YEAH, WELL YOU KNOW, I, I KIND
OF, WHEN MY SON WAS DIAGNOSED
WITH AUTISM A LONG TIME AGO.
>> Jon: RIGHT.
>> AND I ALWAYS KIND OF --
>> Jon: HOW OLD IS DANIEL NOW?
>> HE'S 17 YEARS OLD.
>> Jon: RIGHT.
>> AND I ALWAYS THOUGHT, YOU
KNOW, EARLY ON I KIND OF DIDN'T
WANT TO TALK ABOUT IT, PARTLY
BECAUSE I'M TRIUMPH THE
INSULT COMIC DOG'S HAND UP THE
ASS. AND I KIND OF LIKE
TO -- THERE HE IS.
>> Jon: THERE HE IS.
>> HOW ARE YOU?
>> Jon: HELLO!
>> AND I THOUGHT MAYBE IT'S
BETTER PEOPLE JUST LOOK AT ME AS
AN ASSHOLE, YOU KNOW?
>> Jon: SO IF THEY WERE TO SEE
YOU AS HUMAN --
>> YEAH WELL, IT'S KIND OF
CREEPY ESPECIALLY WHEN
I DO THE VOICE. BUT I FIGURED,
LIKE AT THIS POINT THIS SHOW HAS
GOTTEN SO BIG.
>> Jon: RIGHT.
>> AND IMPORTANT.
>> Jon: YES.
>> THAT LET'S JUST PICTURE IT AS
A COMEDY, AS A CHARITY EVENT
RUN BY AN ASSHOLE. WHAT IF A
CHARITY EVENT WERE RUN BY
SOMEONE WHO'S DISTURBS
BUT WELL MEANING?
>> Jon: VERY WELL MEANING.
YOU KNOW, THERE IS NOTHING I
THINK TO RAISE THE HUMAN SPIRIT
LIKE SEEING PAUL
RUDD ON HIS KNEES.
>> YES. YES.
>> Jon: TAKING FULLY CHEWED WHAT
APPEARED TO BE D'AGOSTINO'S
CHICKEN.
>> I THINK IT WAS ZABAR'S.
>> Jon: WAS THAT A ZABAR'S?
>> YEAH, IT WAS A CLASSY EVENT.
>> Jon: AND THIS GENTLEMAN IN
THE AUDIENCE --
>> YES.
>> Jon: WON THE BIDDING AND CAME
UP.
>> ACTUALLY, THOSE PEOPLE CAME
ON FOR FREE.
>> Jon: FOR FREE.
>> YEAH, A LOT OF THE SHOW IS --
>> Jon: AUCTIONS.
>> AUCTIONS. THE BEACON THEATRE
IS FILLED WITH ABOUT 2500
PEOPLE.
>> Jon: YES.
>> ABOUT 75 OF THEM ARE
REALLY RICH AND CRAZY AND
WILING TO AUCTION, WILLING TO
BID, GOD BLESS THEM.
>> Jon: THEY'RE CRAZY AUCTIONS.
>> THEY WANTED TO SUPPORT THIS
CAUSE.
>> Jon: CHRIS ROCK DID A LIVE
AUCTION IN THE THEATRE,
LOUIS CK TOOK SOMEBODY OUT.
>> YES.
>> Jon: CAN I TELL THEM WHAT
JOHN OLIVER DID?
>> SURE, YEAH.
>> Jon: THEY BID, THERE WAS AN
AUCTION TO BID TO COMMIT A
CRIME WITH JOHN OLIVER.
>> YES, AND IT HAPPENED! THE
CRIME WAS COMMITTED.
[APPLAUSE]
>> Jon: IT WENT OUT THAT NIGHT
WITH A CAMERA AND
COMMITTED A CRIME.
[LAUGHTER]
>> IT'S THE -- IT'S THE WRONGEST
CHARITY EVENT.
>> Jon: AND YET IT'S SO
LOVELY BUT THERE ARE MOMENTS IN
IT.
>> YES.
>> Jon: THE MOMENT WITH OWEN
SUSKIND.
WITH RON SUSKIND'S SON OWEN.
>> WELL YES. THIS IS THE CRAZY
THING THAT ON THE ONE HAND --
>> Jon: YES.
>> PAUL RUDD LITERALLY THIS
HAPPENED THAT WITHIN TEN MINUTES
OF EACH OTHER.
>> Jon: YES. RIGHT BACK TO BACK.
>> PAUL RUDD REGURGITATED,
RECEIVED REGURGITATED FOOD.
>> Jon: FOOD.
>> TEN MINUTES LATER
LITERALLY GILBERT GOTTFRIED WAS
MAKING PEOPLE CRY. YEAH.
>> Jon: BUT, CRY WITH EMOTION
NOT LIKE HE WOULD NORMALLY --
>> WITH EMOTION -- WELL YEAH.
YEAH. NORMALLY THEY'RE CRYING
OUT OF AGONY.
>> Jon: NOT LIKE GILBERT WOULD
NORMALLY DO.
>> YEAH, NOT THE AGONY KIND OF
CRYING HE USUALLY GENERATES.
>> Jon: YES.
>> NO.
IT'S LIKE IT'S AN INCREDIBLE
MOMENT.
>> Jon: IT'S AN INCREDIBLY
MOVING MOMENT WHERE HE ISTHE
CONDUIT THROUGH WHICH THIS YOUNG
MAN OWEN COMMUNICATES HIS
FEELINGS TO HIS FAMILY AND
TO OTHERS AROUND HIM.
>> THAT'S RIGHT.
>> Jon: IT'S AMAZING.
>> RIGHT.
WELL THE WHOLE SHOW IS ABOUT
RAISING MONEY NOT TO CURE
AUTISM.
>> Jon: RIGHT.
>> BECAUSE A LOT OF PEOPLE ARE
WORKING ON BIOMEDICAL RESEARCH.
MY WIFE AND I COULDN'T GET OUR
KID INTO ANY KIND OF SCHOOL OR
PROGRAM THAT WAS ADEQUATE FOR
HIM UNTIL HE WAS SEVEN YEARS
OLD.
AND PEOPLE WITH FEWER RESOURCES
THAN US --
>> Jon: RIGHT.
>> IT'S UNIMAGINABLE TO US WHAT
THEY HAVE TO GO THROUGH.
AND, AND THE KIDS. THEY DESERVE
BETTER.
THESE ARE, YOU KNOW, LAST YEAR
WE HAD A MOMENT, I DON'T KNOW IF
YOU SAW LAST YEAR'S SHOW OR SAW
IT ONLINE, KATY PERRY DID A
DUET.
>> Jon: YES. WITH JODI DIPIAZZA.
>> WITH A LITTLE GIRL.
DID EVERYBODY SEE THAT?
WITH JODI DIPIAZZA?
>> Jon: YEAH, IT WAS AMAZING.
AND SHE, AND THIS LITTLE GIRL
PLAYS THE PIANO AND THEN THERE'S
THIS MOMENT WHERE SHE RECEIVES
SPONTANEOUS APPLAUSE AND SHE
SMILES. AND PEOPLE --
>> Jon: SHE JUST LIGHTS UP.
>> SHE JUST LIGHTS UP.
AND THAT'S THE KIND OF THE THING
PEOPLE ARE SHOCKED, A LOT OF
PEOPLE JUST DON'T UNDERSTAND --
>> Jon: RIGHT.
>> THAT THESE ARE WHOLE HUMAN
BEINGS AND
THEY'RE ENTITLED TO NOT BE
OSTRACIZED AND WRITTEN OFF.
THEY NEED TO BE GIVEN THE CHANCE
TO HAVE THE BEST LIFE AS
POSSIBLE.
>> Jon: RIGHT. YEP.
[APPLAUSE]
>> AND THIS ALLOWS ALL KINDS OF
PROGRAMS. THROUGH OUR SHOW, WE
FUND, WE FUND PROGRAMS ALL OVER
THE COUNTRY, SCHOOLS, PROGRAMS,
A WIDE RANGE OF THINGS.
>> Jon: BUT "THE NIGHT OF TOO
MANY STARS"
THE LIVE AUCTION PART
ON COMEDY CENTRAL THIS SUNDAY
NIGHT, I URGE YOU TO
TUNE IN. IT'S MARCH 8, 8:00 PM.
WE'LL DO A PHONE BANK. WE'LL
SHOW ALL THE GREAT --
>> Jon: YES, LARRY, DAVID AND
MARTY SHORT WILL BE AT THE
PHONE BANK.
>> Jon: THEY'LL BE AT THE PHONE
BANK ALL NIGHT.
WE'LL DO THE SKITS AND
STUFF AT THE BEACON WILL
BE ALL IN THE SHOW.
>> YEAH.
>> Jon: IT'S GOING TO BE GREAT.
OBVIOUSLY JACK AND TRIUMPH
YOU CAN SEE FRIDAY NIGHTS AT
11:30 ON ADULT SWIM.
THE GREAT ROBERT SMIGEL,
EVERYBODY.